we have somebody in our lobby that wants
to ask a live question
he's got the headset on he's standing on
the debt-free stage not doing the debt
free scream
not yet but he wants to ask us a
question in person where we have to look
each other in the eye which is kind of
fun andy this doesn't happen very often
that's really cool so i can't i'm just
overwhelmed to be here today
well we're grateful that you're here so
what's going on man how can we help so i
pastor a church in southern illinois uh
we have about 400 people in attendance
um right before covet started we were
about to
pull the trigger on building a new
sanctuary last year we did our first
financial peaks university class at our
church this year we just started a new
one last week
and man we it's changed my wife myself
my wife's life
matt nick you're here with us today
we've seen a variety of different
families in our church
just greatly changed by the program and
man it's just it's brought in a whole
new attitude
but one of the things going through it
is that we're looking to to borrow
around 2.2 million dollars to build a
new sanctuary
scripture says borrow is slave to the
lender your dave repeats that often
and so i thought do you guys think it's
hypocritical for a church who is
practicing the principles of financial
peace university in their personal lives
to go out and borrow money
in a church setting so before you answer
that
as as somebody who used to meet with
people behind closed doors right on hard
conversations
you get a sense when somebody already
has an answer in their heart
as they're asking the question even
though he framed it so
andy i feel really strongly that you
have
an answer yes walk us through where you
are and how you got there
okay well it goes a little further than
that even and so um
recently god's been doing a great work
in me just through this last year and so
the thought process is is that number
one the answer should be no we shouldn't
we should practice what we preach and if
we tell you to do it in your personal
lives we should do in our church life
secondly the state of illinois is kind
of different right now and i don't want
to go too much into that
but one of the things that we've just
started at our church is to actually
help
families um the the educational
institution illinois is not good
and so one of the reasons for starting
fpu was to help
our families live within their means so
they could help afford christian
education
and so this year our church started to
adopt this program to where we will
partner with a family for up to fifty
percent
of biblical education and every one of
our to every one of our members
just rolled that out wow and so one of
the thought processes is we would rather
we would rather educate our children
than build a building but at the same
time we're literally out of room
right and so it's one of these catch-22s
but you know it's hard to go borrow 2.2
million dollars when you're telling your
families
man live within your means go into
biblical education
exactly and so it's a difficult
situation so i've got a
really strong visceral reaction to this
question for a couple different reasons
but i want to turn it over to the wiser
calmer one of us first what do you think
rachel
i mean you you answered it i mean my
yeah my answer is gonna be
it's consistent so whether it's a bid
someone's opening a business i
never tell them to take out a small
business loan for a church it's the same
way and
and what's difficult though i understand
it's the building constraints but i'll
tell you here at ramsey
we were in a building about 10 miles
north
of where we are right now and we were
outgrowing it and it was like man but
there wasn't cash there to
to buy something and so we could have
you know taken a loan out and
built something like this you know years
and years ago
but we rented out another space and we
rented out another space and we were in
five different buildings and it was
so inconvenient it was not fun we had
like a little shuttle that went around
and like oh it was just it was it was
not
it was not ideal but we move at the
speed of cash around here
and we do that because we really do
believe the borrower is slave to the
lender and your
your whole paradigm shifts again whether
it's a church
whether it's a business what whether
it's your personal life
when you owe someone money the way you
look at things and so
to be able to say man are we invested
into this program like what you guys are
doing is
what how creative and how amazing and
fun
of that education and just move at the
speed of cash
just save over time and it's gonna be
uncomfortable it's not gonna be fun but
also
covid hello you know i mean you couldn't
meet for for months probably
you know so like it it really uh thank
god for covid because if you went and
borrowed two points it literally helped
yeah 2.2 million and couldn't even use
it
at that point so that was that maybe god
may have saved you right there
and for me it's it's it's that and i get
real personal with it
being i tell teenagers i've told
teenagers for years
when they were whining about their
parents this and that my parents this
and i'd always tell them if your parents
are paying for that car
they're paying for that fill in the
blank
they get to speak into it it's theirs
right and
anytime a church a business me
when i hitch myself to somebody else
they get to tell me what to do that's
just the rules right
right and i think sometimes um like i i
find myself speaking out about
it's not because i hate institutions i
think institutions actually do wonderful
stuff on broad
big scales but man when i owe somebody
they get to tell me what to do and i
there's a lot of yelling and screaming
these days
and people don't don't they forget that
man i hitch myself to that wagon
most most recently in my life i haven't
had a mortgage in a while
right i got one recently and i'm having
trouble
sleeping because i am
now in debt to the bank right and they
get to tell me
nope you're going to keep going to work
every day you're going to keep filling
the blank right right
and so i'm going to tell you i think a
remarkable conversation
for a leader in a church right now is to
stand up and say
this is going to be messy we're going to
figure it out
but we're gonna do the right thing and
we are not gonna hitch our wagon to
a state a bank a federal government
or whatever and it's not is it gonna be
inconvenient yep are we gonna have to
have 14 services and do all this weird
whatever
yep right um but i think it's the right
thing to do
right and i'm just grateful for your
heart man oh absolutely and i would say
this too
as someone who attends a church when i
know because our church is debt-free
they paid off
all of their building debt about four
years ago and it was incredible and so
now
i know when i tithe that it's not going
to bank of america
right you know it's not going to an
interest payment it's literally going to
a single mom
because we have a whole car's ministry
and it's buying single mom cars like
that's like
that's what it's like it's going it's
going to my pastor right to help pay his
salary
the church staff like i know where my
money's going
and as a as a someone who tithes and
gives i'll tell you the heart of your
congregation to have that conversation
with john just said
yeah that builds trust and honestly i
think that's a that's a beautiful
conversation just to say it out loud
yeah and i'm really sad i'm only putting
one foot on a soapbox here because
i could get myself in trouble i wish
every
every church in america any denomination
would have a hard look in the mirror and
say how much money are we paying to
the salaries of our local bankers that
could be going to
feeding the kids in our communities that
could be putting kids in schools that
could be helping single moms
we do a lot of bickering and yelling
about you know government intrusion and
social programs and we sure like new
shiny things in churches yeah that's
that's been the heart is that you know
especially with this education program
is you know
churches right now we're losing seven to
one and so for every seven kids in this
generation we're only getting one back
in the next
and my thought was man if we build a
building in 20 years we cannot have
people to put in it that's right if we
don't start investing in our kids now
and the big heart is is that you know
you pay this much money each month to a
for
brick and mortar you know when you can
invest man in in the
in the future of our yeah our kids
coming up yeah and we're not mad at
brick and mortar no not at all
absolutely like it's it's a great thing
you got the space yeah praise god yeah
something about being in this direction
yep
moving at the speed of cash so i think
you know it i mean even the way you
asked the question that was a great call
i hope every single small business owner
i hope every single non-profit leader
hope every single pastor
in this country is listening this
conversation and listening to your heart
man
because the more money we pass out in
other people's salaries that could be
going to healing these communities
right we the only gap person to fill
that gap becomes the government right
that's the greatest one of the biggest
problems we have in society today is the
church isn't playing the role of the
church
right right america he said it not me
just kidding i'm with you brother i'm
with you i'm with you i'm with you
amen so ben i appreciate your heart and
financial beast university we talk about
what can the people of god do for the
kingdom of god if they had no debt
and that's on an individual basis but we
say yeah you put the government out of
business right like
as believers if you didn't have your car
payments your credit cards your student
loans
and you were able to give outrageously
that is literally the movement that is
what changes
so we did our our finished university
class last year our giving went up
almost a hundred thousand dollars
amazing brothers well thank you so much
bless you guys appreciate you
oh man pay
off your debts and then give recklessly
yep